foreign
good evening ladies and gentlemen
may I welcome you all
to this meeting of the Torrance District
Council community and resources
committee
we are on YouTube we welcome the members
of the public who are watching
um
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence thank you chair one apology
councilor Brenton councilor Brenton no
substitute right
next item on the agenda is the minutes
of the last meeting held on the 3rd of
July I think it was
um
at 24th of July my apologies
write reading from the bottom
page three
page four
yes councilor Christie
no I agree with you and I did discuss
this with the chief executive day
um
there is little Point having it on the
forward plan when you consider that this
is a decision-making committee and we
need a proposal in front of us to make a
decision to
so we're just going to keep popping up
for the sake of it seems to me which is
all rather pointless but I know what
you're saying
I'll come back on that because at some
point we're going to have to spend some
money and if it doesn't come from this
committee where does it come from it
comes from this committee
so we should have it on our forward plan
just remind us that we keep needing to
look at it it'll come up with a gppc
because we won't get a new local plan
without we get sorted on them
so if is it going to be on the forward
plan because I would like it to be there
if I need to keep reminding I know how
you feel five years ago when it was all
we were rushing about trying to find
something all went very quiet after that
and everyone seemed to forget about it
try I guess we could add it as a
footnote to the low uh the forward plan
it's not worth putting it in as a a set
time frame at this stage because there's
no uh set time for entry to be
considered
um if you put it on the next meeting
just keep moving it and moving it so we
haven't set the meeting that the first
meeting of the jpbc in this
Administration is next week the 22nd of
September but that won't be set in a
time frame although the head of
communities in place and I had a
discussion earlier about try it see if
we can get that early on the agenda
because it's a piece of work that can be
started
um even without understanding the scope
of a new local plan so it's something
that would need to be done so and
obviously if
it's a piece of torrage land that might
be proposed then obviously that would be
for this committee to consider and if
there's any Resource as in finances that
would need to be that would need to come
through the budget process so that would
be something
um to be considered later planning
is it still joined it's still a joint
planning policy committee yes
so have North Devon agreed that is going
to be a full
one or
do they still want the partial one
they haven't taken anything back to
their full Council as yet
very much so
what did I get to item
a page four
page five
eight six
that's it
are we happy uh councilor James
proposed seconded counselor lock all in
favor please show
one two three
uh
good afternoon good evening members um
so very briefly
um the revenue and benefits Department
currently use a project a document
Imaging system
um so when correspondence or documents
comes in in relation to a Pacific's
client's file that documentation is
scanned online so it it goes along with
the client's file instead of having
paper copies the current system that
they've had they've had since 2008.
um and from November this year it's no
longer going to be supported so there
won't be any updates or bug fixes on the
system
um
so the proposal in the PID document is
that we upgrade the system
to run alongside the current welfare
benefit system so we can carry on
scanning in the document
documents make sure that we're legally
compliant and comply with data
protection principles as well the
initial outlay is is more but the annual
maintenance fee is less than the current
system so a total savings storage of 305
000 over the 10-year period
I'm happy to take any questions
yeah what why can't the documents just
be scanned in and put into a file
on Windows I mean that's what I do all
the time yeah we have an online system
now for the revs and Benz um system so
all client files are on online so you
may have remember we brought um a report
through to CNR before
um so we're long people can self-serve
on on the system
um so landlords benefit applicants can
self-serve on the system so their
documents go alongside their file online
and it saves on storage actually it
saves on having large amounts of paper
and paper files
I thought an external hard drive would
do that but there are
and yeah just as you did has there been
any process just to go check with any
other authorities regarding what they
use I guess this is something that's
used
or potentially used by other authorities
as well I didn't know whether yeah
there's one of two providers
um capital
and
The Other Name Escapes me at the moment
but yes so our reps and Ben's manager
Joe Wells is on meetings of all other
revs and Ben's managers within in the
area
we've already taken out the annual
license under the current system
and yet we're which we paid 37 900
pounds for
to cover 23-24
why couldn't we have decided earlier
that we're going to have to change the
system
and save that and taking on this new
system earlier
we must have known it was coming we'll
get that payment back Pro rata we'll get
that payment back Pro rata we will will
we
so we have to have a system to do it
um and we can carry on with this system
it's just that it's not not the best
thing to do bearing in mind this is not
going to be supported any longer
I just second
types of James is supposedly to push it
through
um no one else waiting to speak
um
so
let me leave the storm
thank you chair I shouldn't be tackling
anybody tonight tonight thanks everybody
nice to see you I'm Adrian Avery
Community engagement officer and this
this one has come about from so we I sit
on we have a an active travel working
group for a torrage which consists of
members and other other bodies as well
I'll read through the purpose of the
report hopefully you've all seen for
members to decide if creating and
promoting a recreational cycle stroke
active travel route through Victoria
Park and Biddeford is favorable using
existing pathways
um this is this is a an active Travel
Group sort of recommendation
um we were we trying to promote active
travel around our area as much as
possible through cycling and walking and
trying to establish
um routes where possible and we managed
to create the local cycling and walking
infrastructure plan with with Devon
County Council joint plan with
Barnstable and Northern and Biddeford
not so long ago which is which has been
published which we're all working
towards which gives us a good a good
document to try and investigate funding
where possible and this little bit of
Route is is part of that plan it's
suggested as part of that plan we're
trying to think of ways as best as
possible
um one to link up with Biddeford and
trying trying to stab in our narrow
towns with the space we have so we're
just trying to make use of the
opportunities where possible but also
the has the health benefits of trying to
get people cycling and walking as more
more than we are currently
um I won't go through the report like so
hopefully you've all seen it but
um in terms of a conclusion it's for TDC
officers and working member group
Fearless preferred route would increase
safety and enjoyability of the park and
provide a link to Encore active travel
through bitifici to Northern encourage
in all ages and abilities to walk and
cycle away from the busy roads and
create another enjoyable environment to
be physically active
we know there's um another link coming
up from our Housing Development beyond
beyond past our TDC offices and heading
up towards Northam so hopefully it will
it will link up with part of that in the
long run
um so our recommendation is for CNR
committee to consider TDC creating a
cycle opportunity through Victoria Park
as preferred recreation community option
compared to others that might be or
might not be available
for any questions
[Music]
yes I haven't got that map in front of
me but I know I know I know where you
mean so what we'd like to do
my my
long-term ambition the blue is a
long-term ambition the red is what is
currently there and already in place
with Pathways that are wide enough which
link with what we call the
L120 document which um came out from
Boris Johnson's
um ideas a few years ago so that's what
we all work towards
um in terms of cycle guidance and width
of Pathways and safety so we kind of
already have that around there as well
the blue line
um is a bit of a dream it's a bit of a
an ambitious should be able to secure
funding
um to go around the outside of King
George V fields which will create an
extra pathway opening up extra space for
our dog walkers our Walkers our Runners
that use the park the park run currently
does that route in the summer when it's
dry but when it's in the winter and it's
wet they have to go out onto the road
and turn around and come back Crossing
each other which isn't ideal we've
consulted with the park run and they've
I think they've raised it years ago
before and never been able to do any
fundraising to get that sort of thing
but I would like to if it was possible
considering section 106 money that we
trying to get in from housing
developments that we could create that
extra safe space because it will get it
would get congested on that little bit
of red line going past the rugby pitch
the outside rugby pitch if you like
um thank you Joe
um yeah just to give the background this
proposals come come out of
the active Travel Group which I chair
and it was proposed that we put it to
this committee it's also part of the LC
web which you've has been referred to
and I should say that the whole thing of
active travel comes out of a torrage
resolution which was passed uh two or
three years ago to promote cycling and
walking
and it fits in with our climate
emergency objectives as a council
this scheme as I say in my lead members
comments would complete a strategic path
and it would provide the opportunity for
children to learn how to ride in a safe
environment
it would have health honesty health
benefits and also contribute to
reduction of carbon emissions
the officers are behind this scheme
they're very much against going along
the key because of the problems of
mixing with cars
this is not an unusual proposal all over
the country there are cycleways through
parks in the Royal parks in London and
other cities
locally Advanced or Rock Park and pilton
or UK as a as an objective
and I should say that if the route was
completed through to the key that there
would be a strategic opportunity to join
the Tarka Trail so that there'll be wide
benefits there is also funding available
for this scheme as I understand it so I
commend it to this committee
okay what you got
chairman I'm a woman
wouldn't want to think I want
um in favor of cycling although from a
personal perspective I'm considered to
be lethal and a bicycle but there you
are
um I'm a bit worried about this I'm not
worried about the fact it's going to go
through the park but I am worried about
the route that's going to go through the
park and when I look at the map it's
going to go very close to the paddling
pool where lots of families and children
congregate or through spirits on the
Tarka trailer is that when people are
cycling sometimes
they don't consider anybody else so it
really does bother me I think great idea
perhaps not the route that you decided
on thank you
I was just going to say make exactly the
same point as characters at Whitaker
actually I think it's too near the um
paddling pool have you got full funding
for this already then
so so what we have is um we have a bit
of funding through a shared Prosperity
fund which we had we had cost very rough
costs um sent in for creating signage
and and white line marking like you'll
see in most Parks we'd be able to
achieve that but also what we could do
with that is and I'll take your point
about the route exactly so we could use
that to commission a better design and
use it and bringing people in to advise
us otherwise what I would say is that we
have consulted with Devon County Council
highways officers I can't remember what
Martin Cathy's official title is but he
developed these routes around certainly
in around Flemington recently as well
and available like Bank end car park and
past our offices all obviously main
roads
foreign
this is one of the most kakamani ideas
I've seen from this Council in a long
time when I saw this report I couldn't
believe what I was looking at
why create a problem where non-exists
putting the bikes into the park as
councilor Whitaker said
I mean any day of the week you can go
down and see cyclists coming down past
Riverbank house along the footpath there
through the car park and the hands will
go down land of this hill way or they go
down the footpath which is two meters
wide boarded in the car park in the park
or they just go down through the car
park itself no problem and that joins up
then with the cycleway on the key
but to root this round here like this I
absolutely ludicrous you're going to
come along
past instead of coming up to Riverbank
house you'll go around then you go
through the car park there then you go
up the sloping footpath to the Rugby
Club right along in front of the Rugby
Club right where the Children's Center
is at the other end then you turn right
there then you head towards the bowling
room where a lot of Elder people come in
and out through the raw 10 Gates and use
that then you turn left and go down that
long path and this Council of Whittaker
says straight past the paddling pool
where children are where people picnic
and then out through the main gates I
mean it's absolutely ludicrous when a
direct route which is used currently by
cyclists is to come along past River
Bank house down there and then when you
get down you can either diver and go
down land of a sealway you can either go
through the carpet or keep on that
footpath that goes straight down I'm not
supporting this I think it's a ludicrous
idea and I reckon most people ignore it
anyway and Carry On Using what they do
know
I can't believe that this has been put
forward in a serious way
it's a job to add to those comments but
I I would support what comes the leather
said and what comes to Whitaker said and
coconut lock said
um I looked at it with some disbelief
um and I have a little points which
Adrian's partly picked up on is the
money from the walls sparsity so I've
got the wrong glasses Prosperity yeah
um fund I wondered you know what that
was going into because that's capital
spend rather than Revenue as I've
learned in the last few days and also on
the risk assessment it said experts
some of the experts have sort of said it
was okay in roundabout speaking subject
to things I can't think of anything
worse we we've got a problem at
bridgewell school at the moment with
cyclists coming down the hill hell for
leather and coming
um and you know I I can't see so I was
in the park the other week having an ice
cream when I've got a free 10 minutes
and there was a cyclist come through
then and there was four children walking
along the path and they were expected to
step out of the way is that what it's
going to be priority to cyclist
um I can't vote for it I'm sorry
right I sit on the active Travel Group
and I have raised my concerns about this
at the group there are various concerns
actually that I understood there was a
bylaw forbidding cycling in the park I
think it's still in order and the other
thing was you may remember councilor
bushby getting very excited about the
Travelers and wanting the gates fixed so
this will only be open when the parts
open as I understand it because we can't
leave the gate open just for cyclists
and then all the Travelers come through
so it'll only be open for a certain time
of day which I'm not sure if that's what
we're aiming for
um another one is I look under next
delivery steps and it says funds are
available through the shared Prosperity
fund is there a cut-off date for that
because I think this needs to go back
and to be looked at again
is there a cut-off date
we would use that by the end of March
profiled into in the shared Prosperity
fund it fits in this year because it's a
number of three year program if it's in
this year uh Adrian's right it's the end
of March if it's profiled for next year
then you've got that 12 months to March
25. yeah
fully support the comments given by
councilor Haynes I think
as a society we um I think as a society
we really do need to think differently
about travel
um
cars are causing us all sorts of
problems so you know to say that there's
an existing situation without any
problems I think is
um a bit blinded
um I really like the proposal I did give
it quite a lot of thought
came up I don't know the area as well as
probably others in this room got you
know a similar Park in holesworthy I
ride my bike through that part three or
four times
a week and I think there's definitely a
change when you come off a road or a
cycleway into a park environment
psychologically you realize you are
sharing it not with cars anymore you're
sharing it with people which is relaxing
actually
I think we need to think about getting
safe and green travel routes in our area
I think there's a bit of hyperbole in
society at the moment about cyclists you
know some of the comments there about
cyclists being near children in a park
you know we're talking about cyclists on
bikes we've got good Vision
um you can only go fast if you put
particular effort in
it's as if we were talking about
bringing machine guns into the park
there of some of those comments
um also with no you know comment about
Bridge rule school people coming down
the hill fast I could see that being a
problem thanks sorry James but we're not
talking about no um Steve Hills and and
school entrances here you know I'd like
to think we work as a council to
overcome the potential problems and I
think you know as I put in my comments
into the report and I've had actually a
couple of representations from people
who live in Westward Ho raising slight
concerns and I think that's I've spoken
to Adrian about this
um you know it can be managed you know
to say to people as they're entering in
the park
slow cyclists you know put some rules
put some good signage up I'm not overly
keen on creating Lane sometimes because
I think it gives people it separates
people so I think if you can have
mixes of pedestrians children playing
people on bikes I think people are
generally tend to be quite sensible
as somebody did say you know there is
another you said Chris's and there's
another option I think if people
probably want to bomb through that area
they'll carry on going through the car
park out there
um at the risk of cars reversing out
into them which could be a problem
um I'd actually like us to go a step
further push forward with this project
and in really try and encourage people
to to
to use the cycling option
um I think
people go on autopilot sometimes they
just get in their cars I don't think
people realize how good it can be if you
just get your bike quite often quicker
definitely cheaper definitely better for
you
um you know bike stands and things like
that I had noted here but that was
probably being a bit positive because it
sounds like people are a bit into this
project which I find disappointing
coming out and getting in the way of
people on bicycles they just wouldn't
realize what the danger was so if you're
going to put it in the park you have to
find the very best route you can and the
farthest away from children
sorry about that but that's how I feel
I don't see too much of a problem with
this and I find it bizarre that we're
talking about worrying about cyclists
when you've got children in a paddling
pool if their parents aren't looking
after them in a paddling pool then
there's no hope at all so quite frankly
I don't see any issue with this it's you
know at the end of the day it's life
skill looking after yourself we've all
got to learn it whether you're old
whether you're young you take your life
in your hands when you just walk out
your door
right
yeah
I just wonder if anyone can say a little
bit more about what it would actually
look like so you talked about having
lines painted are you imagining that
it's going to be a cyclists separated
off or just lines painted to show this
is where this is the cycling route that
goes through the park what will actually
be like yeah so it's more about guidance
and and safety usage really of the area
so that advice from Devon County Council
officers that are doing this regularly
are advising that we we're not
separating
it's it's more directional than anything
else and areas where we can't go and we
don't want them to go you know close to
the paddling pool
um in around the play areas and and the
Burton potentially because we know that
gets busy as a pinch Point as well so so
it's more about directional than than
separating we don't really want to be
separating we learned themselves and
possible
yes
Disturbed all right so implication of
cyclists
just think that's a huge number of
accidents and Motorcars every year
we need to create these same spaces
mixing
cycle Trail which I think is
this committee is
recommend that further work is done on
the design and possibly a consultation
you'll have to go to consultation
publicly anyway
for the observation of six people
James yeah just make the point that the
thing that worries me with cyclists is
when you met some of my children they
can't hear the bikes coming and that is
an issue I'm not anti-cyclist I've spent
years trying to bring the view to
holster this Cycle Way Forward I've also
got a son who is a mad cyclist who does
300 mile
tracks and things like that so I'm not
anti-cyclist I am concerned where that
route is is very close to where the
children will be running towards the
pool running towards the play area and
you've got cyclists coming through and I
just think you know the risk is not I'm
not prepared to put children at that
risk as simple as that not that I'm
against cyclists I fully support it and
I take Umbridge vet Linden that I have
spent a long time sorry Carissa Piper
trying to get the cycle away into
holdsworthy and and it's a safety issue
for me with the children
foreign
because it's irrelevant how much you've
tried what your whether your son rides a
thousand miles a week this is about the
subject with all typeless well it's
obvious that the cyclists avoid the
children
as I said I ride my bike three to four
times through a public park which is a
very busy public part
um
and you slow down you slow down and you
weave your way through because that
that's very obvious I mean cyclists have
to do this all of the time whenever
they're riding on a road or whether
they're riding in a park it's it's
it's ridiculous to think that we've got
some reason the cyclists are just
missiles coming through a park and their
toddler's got to be aware
um I don't think we're putting toddlers
at risk I think if we're doing this and
maybe we should go back to all the
public parks in this country and start
reviewing whether cyclists should be
allowed in parks and crikey that's a
step backwards
[Music]
well interesting to listen to the
comments
councilor Ames mentioned in other Parks
because there's no alternative here
there is an alternative a safer
alternative we don't have to mix
cyclists with power with children or
people in parks and there is a I think
still enforce this Bible I don't know if
we've heard from the fields in trust at
all yet about this proposal no doubt
they will comment on it but as I said
you can go any day of the week and see
people cycling they go down through the
car park or they go down on the visual
walk or they go on the pavement which is
two nearly two meters wide right the way
along the plot on the outside of the
park
those of us who walk and go on the
target Trail no there are good and bad
cyclists there are cyclists who are very
good they'll ring the bell when they're
coming behind you there's a lot who
don't
and it suddenly jump out the way
it's not just the paddle in pool it's
the Children's Center it'll go past it's
the elderly people going into the
Bowling Club I mean it's just ludicrous
to create a problem where none exists
and I don't see I just can't support it
when there is perfectly good alternative
routes a more straightforward for
cyclists to be honest chair
can I can I come back in that chair
yeah sorry thank you um just just a few
points on that and mostly that before
you mentioned it I've written the fields
and trust and we have engaged with them
and they do fully support them and we
don't have to we don't have to consult
with them again should we want to go
ahead with it
um they're fully supportive of active
travel through all their protected
spaces I'm happy to share that as well
um
and also uh sorry specifically through
Victoria Park in Biddeford then they've
supported that their comments where they
support all
um through not specifically it's one of
their protected spaces so they they were
happy with it a general comment
I'm sorry just just continue on with
that I think it's about a couple of bits
there also about the type of cyclists
that we're talking about and those those
commuters and those very quicker Keen
cyclists will still go up past TDC
offices and down through the car park
and use the highway code like they have
done and no one's going to stop them
doing that that's absolutely fine and
they'll carry on doing that and this is
more about possibly a nicer recreational
route and thinking about the school
times of the year you know with those
busy times 12 times 12 weeks of the year
I just completely understand that they
are going to be busy and we hopefully be
able to manage that but the rest of the
year it's it's fairly quiet times it'll
be a lovely a lovely bypass for those
wanting to enjoy a quieter Park as well
Park long long gone
[Music]
um
I think we do need to support the idea
of a cycleway between Northern and
Biddeford that's obvious that is needed
because you don't want to go along the
main roads
I would like to know about because at
active travel I've always suggested we
go through the car park I much prefer
that but have we got any accident
figures for the car park have there been
any accidents for the cyclists because I
can't remember any and before people say
oh you've got a mix cyclists and cars
you go to the car park all the drivers
go so I don't see why cyclists can't go
through as well they already do as
counselor leather said but I go back to
what it says on page 24 at the bottom
there
the next delivery steps seek further
design to show specified walk and cycle
zones with due considerations in the
busy areas of the park
now councilor Haynes did propose we go
back we look at this again and have a
perhaps have a consultation if he's
proposing that as a proper proposer I'll
second it
let's start
foreign
I've just been reliably informed that by
the paddling pool there is a wall and a
gate that actually prevents the children
mixing with the cyclists if you really
want to be this precious about the nanny
State we're living in the fact people
can't think for themselves and people
can't hear for themselves and oh my God
we might have electric cars soon
everywhere that actually make no noise
either you know frankly I think you're
really overthinking this
um the other aspect of it is it's fine
to go out to consultation but please
don't waste the money that we have on
Consultants
because
I've been lectured long and hard about
the choices we have to make because we
have no money and if we are to go to
Consultants on this then
what makes mockery the whole thing quite
frankly something as simple as this
you're massively overthinking it I feel
um discuss the planning application you
look at what is exactly in front of you
you don't compare it to Hyde Park or
rotten row or any country don't you know
any parts up the country so I am still
concerned about the proposal
these cars can cause
there's plenty of history of cyclists
being killed by cars over the country we
just didn't check us a general comment
Who's going to share with the psychosome
I'll come a secondary but no proposal
the Hamish proposes chemistor Christy
seconds
that we move forward
making queries with consultation and
that type of thing is that correct
let's try to evolve it was in favor of
that proposal is shown
three four
those games
five
extensions
we now move on to item 11.
Victoria Park
play area centerpiece
Plumbing concern
Ed the principle is here is this
committee prepared to authorize
catch the crystal I've got to declare an
interest as a member of the British
trust we're giving you quite a lot of
money
and that's what we're considering to
make an application for this centerpiece
in the park
s if we don't see what
this is
because to see I wish to find their own
social media area well
Adrian and Sean came to the British
trust to discuss it with us so yes we
have seen it
would it would it help if I just quickly
describe the scheme because what we're
not asking members of this committee to
to decide onto the planning merits of
The Proposal because we're asking for
you for permission to let plans
committee make that call
it's been a project that's been in our
books for quite a while now to get the
play area in Victoria Park organized
Adrian and a guy called Robin Glover who
represented the community have managed
to pull together a really good scheme
and accumulated the funds to be able to
deliver it so the funding will come from
the rural Prosperity fund some of
toridge's money and contribution from
the bridge trust as mentioned by cancer
Christie
so
the job's been tendered the tenders come
back the company
to deliver that has been selected but as
part of their design there's a
centerpiece that requires planning
permission now we kind of had assumed I
think that this would all be done under
the council's permitted development
writing application because we would
expect others in the community to make
that application so what we're not
asking you to do is tell us whether or
not you think the play area is a good
one it's whether it's whether we can
supply apply uh make a planning
application for that play area to the
plans committee peace
yeah I apologize if I'm I'm obviously
new and I've come into this part way
through but from what I can see that's
been a very good public consultation
process Community seems to have huge
buy-in
as Sean says it's not necessarily but
that is going through the process which
seems absolutely straightforward to me
obviously going through planning it will
mean it will go up for consultation for
everybody anyway so if there are any um
nasties hiding out there I'm sure
they'll come out as part of the planning
process but from what I can see it's uh
um really well thought through scheme
and lots of work gone into it and I
would say as a totally fresh set of eyes
I walked into Victoria Park I get
pressure from our my end of the world
that all the money spent in Biddeford
and things and I walked into Victoria
Park I thought okay it needs this
because it's our percent of Peace Park
and
um it looks like it needs a new play
area so I just think we yeah it's a yes
for me
propose we go forward however it needs
to be wired head sorry yeah I'm not sure
if counselor Piper was actually
proposing it goes to planning or not
there yeah I think I was was that yeah
I'll second it yes um if you've seen the
plans
um they are quite breathtaking actually
um it has been put on social media by Mr
Glover
and it's received a lot of very positive
comments
um the only issue I would raise and this
came up at the bridge trust and I'm
sorry about this that
um
torridge is hoping to open it at
Christmas
and I thought what in the middle of
winter are it's going to be an iconic
thing it really is and I notice in our
report on base 31 at the top it says the
money's got to be spent by March 24. if
you've got to be spent by then can we
open it at Easter it seems to be much
you know much more obvious time to open
it rather than Christmas I mean
presumably we are going to have quite a
big opening and a big Fanfare and all
this
um and it seemed to appear hard to open
it in the coldest period of the year
I don't know
or for planning permission but what
disappoints me is
and I do like to keep my eyes and ears
open I've never seen anything
it's been anti-tender it's been
obviously approved by some of it
I've known until councilor Christie put
that up from social media I haven't seen
anything of it I don't know whom at
storage or what committee at storage has
seen it all and has approved it that
I've never seen it before but I mean
this is a planning application yeah but
it's all the planet
I was going to ask are we at Liberty to
know which company you've gone with yeah
yeah correct yeah
so I know that yeah
you know it really irritates me chair
that kind of thing you know
we're all working together for torridge
office is a member elected members and
then something like this we're all in
the dark about it
you know it's just not on that
six weeks
can I ask one further question how high
is this High piece of equipment than the
in these planning applications because I
dealt with zip wires going in I mean and
they start off eyes why is it so high
so uh again Adrian will correct me if
it's wrong because he's run the job but
it's uh nine and nine and a half meters
from the ground to the top of the
structure isn't it just below just below
nine meters yes below nine meters there
you are yeah
that's the top of the structure so that
people will be sending obviously
this committee was presented with a
number of designs was it last year I
remember coming to another Highway for
any preference
chair I can again yeah there's
definitely a presentation I did it
myself and I know Adrian's done a lot of
consultation widely around the place as
Robin
um we didn't release the the pictures
onto social media because we weren't we
felt that there was a protocol for that
and and perhaps the pictures were
released outside of toridge's
communication controls so we're just
just to clarify that
um
um I think that was all I was going to
say
those in favor
that's unanimous thank you
um